I love problems like this, they're so much fun,
they're like logic puzzles you have to work through. Even
if you don't get them right the first try, it's
really fun to keep going, and try to gather as
much information as you can, to make the best possible
guess. In this case the answer I was looking for
is 1 6th, or one out of six. You might
have also had 1.6 repeating. Or something around 16.6% repeating,
something like that. Fractions are easier to deal with
here so let's try to work with that. Let's think
about this for a second. We know it's an autosomal
recessive pedigree so if that's true, it means males and
females are affected equally because this is on an autosomes
somewhere. This affected male here, this must mean that he
is homozygous recessive. If he's homozygous recessive, we know that
his parents had at least one recessive copy a piece,
because he would have had to have gotten both
of his copies from his parents. Well, they must
have a recessive copy, but they're not affected. This
means they must have a dominant, normal copy here. So
his parents must be heterozygous. We figured all that
out already. So now let's look at his siblings. We
know they're not affected so they're not minus minus,
but they could be either plus plus or plus minus.
Right, so there are two options here. Let's focus on
this female, because this female is involved in the reproductive
event here. So to figure out what the probability is
that this individual is heterozygous because that's the only way that
they can pass this allele on and have an affected
child. Is we gotta figure out the probability of this individual
being heterozygous. We're going to do the Punnet squares of the
parents. Right if the mom and dad here are both hets.
Then we could either have a plus plus, a
plus minus, a plus minus, or a minus minus.
Now, we know already it can't be a minus
minus. So let's get rid of that option right
there. That gives us three options left. Two out
of three of those are the het. So we're
going to say she's a two thirds probability. Of being
heterozygous. Now let's do the same thing over here.
We know that the mother is infected, which means
that she is homozygous recessive, in the same way
that we figure it out over here. Her son
is unaffected. So that means he must have at
least one normal dominant copy. But he must also
have one recessive copy, because the mother only had
a recessive copy to give. So he must be
heterozygous. That's a probability of one that he's heterozygous. Now,
if he's heterozygous and the person he's mating with
is also heterozygous. Set up their Punnett squares. They
could have a plus plus, a plus minus, a
plus minus, or a minus minus. Only one of these
cases is an effected individual, the homozygous recessive, so
that's one in four. So now what we have
to do is multiply all our probabilities together. We
don't add them we multiply them. So the probability that
this guy is heterozygous. Is one. So we do one. The probability that
the mother is heterozygous is 2 3rds and the probability that they'll actually
have an offspring that's affected is 1 4th. So this would be 2 over 12
which is equal to 1 over 6. Now, that's a simple one.
Imagine if I gave you a hard one. Hopefully,
you'll have a little more respect for those genetic counsellors.